i hope you guys were like a little bit
nostalgic and
the least bit as excited as we are to
see you all back together again
rachel wrote ross a letter and demanded
he read it before they got back together
how many pages was that letter 18 pages
18
pages front and back front and back is
correct wait wait don't worry
when you walked on that stage and you
were all back together here what was
that feeling like matthew i'm going to
start with
uh we've had a wonderful couple of days
it's been very nostalgic and
uh and and really just heartwarming
couple of days
uh being on the set and seeing this
seeing the old set
and uh seeing the crew and seeing the
scene seeing the the old guys and
it's just it's a very loving group
one of the not old guys the yeah
the older guy they are older than i am
yeah we are
we're older i am the youngest yeah
matthew's the youngest so he can get
away with saying that but seeing uh
seeing uh schwimmer and maddie and
well at least you got our names and lisa
and
courtney and jenny um
you know it's a it's a very loving
tight-knit
group and when we see each other it's a
it's a very heartwarming thing
it's it's interesting that you say that
matthew because um
david like not every tv series you know
the cast from from these shows stay as
close as you guys
did and are what about this experience
of making this series
did that for you all that made this such
a bonding experience
i think uh i think first of all we um
we felt from the from the first table
read of the pilot without having met
any of the others beforehand we all felt
kind of an instant chemistry
going way back um and then when we were
shooting the pilot i think that
really solidified that chemistry
solidified
this is from the one where everyone
finds out
i remember being incredibly impressed
with the other five actors i just
thought this was the best casting i had
ever seen
or been a part of and then over the 10
years obviously
we really grew close as a family and
part of the reason was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to or or was
going through except the other five
actors so
um we really we really got close because
of
that experience too okay
[Applause]
is that the girls and you're on another
yeah this is a three shot i think are
you into three shots seeing me do that
i think so i look crazy that's a crazy
person
so first of all matthew the over under
on how many times today you're gonna
hear
could you be any more excited how many
times you're going to hear that i've
heard that a lot i've heard that a lot
but i like hearing that
i'm going to do this while matthew's
talking
so turn around i thought i wasn't on
camera
and we're hearing the other interviews
so i thought people were just talking
do it to you every single time this is
like old times i mean
this makes girls totally upstage in the
guys
so when i go to them you guys gotta get
them back like i just say
run through the damn interview just
don't you worry about it i'm sure
there you go it's on it's on it's on
you guys this was so much fun i it does
it does my heart some good seeing you
all back together again
thank you very much too thanks for your
time thank you very much and sorry for
acting like a crazy person girls
upstaging the guys
why would they schedule these interviews
on the same stage that's a great
question
so anything we could afford was one step
all we could afford was one stage
apparently
i hear you hey matt um so for you what
do you think
that all these characters we'll start
with joe what do you think joey would be
doing in 2021
uh joey triviani in 2021 would uh
probably be oh he would be he'd have ten
kids he'd have ten kids be brain dead
yeah brain dead in the unemployment line
well he i probably wouldn't be acting
right i mean
he'd still be trying why not yeah maybe
you'd be what are you saying running a
garage or something
okay well analyze these two what about
chandler and what about ross
well chandler would be involved in the
computer
world somehow but we don't know he'd be
coaching his kids soccer game and ross
would be
uh running the museum playing with the
bones
playing with the bones
playing with the ball just playing with
them
just be playing with the bones
they really enjoyed that over on lisa's
interview
you can't write that okay well before we
leave then let's analyze the women since
they've just integrated
shut up shut up
what's phoebe doing what's monica doing
what's rachel you're making a lot of
dance
you